your birthday wish today on your
birthday a million more wishes yep it's
Britney Spears's birthday the singer is
officially 38 years old and to celebrate
she had a day of fun in Miami with her
man Sam asghari life is amazing Britt
shared this video montage on Instagram
showing off some of the highlights from
her bday festivities naturally she
captioned the clip
it's my bday [ __ ] so what did Britney
do to ring in another year well
according to her insta post she spent
the day relaxing on the beach bowling
ice skating checking out some epic sand
sculpture art and soaking up quality
time with her beau oh and check out that
giant cake yep those are pics past and
present of Britney all over that cake
and what would a birthday be without a
few balloons cute it's nice it's very
good meanwhile Sam brought some major
fields writing a heartfelt message in
honor of the birthday girl
he captioned this hilarious video of him
wiping out hard on the ice quote we live
we laugh we argue and most of all we
love there's a reason why the world fell
in love with you you might be the
princess of pop but mostly you're my
princess biggest happy birthday to you
Britney Spears um
swoon you see marriage in the future I
mean absolutely this is something that
every couple should do that's the whole
point of a relationship we're a family
and as Britt turns another year older a
source tells ET that she is doing
incredibly well adding her family is
very proud of the steps she's taken to
get where she is today
Britney's been following her doctor's
orders and is in a very stable place at
the moment and the source explained that
right now
Britney's focus is on Sam and her two
sons with ex Kevin Federline 14 year old
Shawn and 13 year old Jayden quote she
is trying to keep life simple and spend
time with Sam and her kids how's your
relationship with the kids
it's obviously you got to be stuff daddy
now yeah yeah
Disneyland everything's great happy
families met yes yeah absolutely
we'll just use your mom like you've
sisters or anything I have three sisters
oh and they're like yeah Sam's bring
home Brittany freakin Spears to dinner
yeah we've hung out a lot of times you
know we went together for three years my
sister's love her my family loves her my
mom lives in another country when she
was here she met her oh my love then
life seems pretty good for you life is
amazing holy mackerel who would have
thought one little call for music video
it would change your life in this way
right
[Music]
happy birthday Brittany we love you here
at ET and we are so grateful for another
year of you of course will be here to
bring you all the Brittany updates so
make sure to keep it locked right here
until next time I'm Hallie Stevens see
you soon
[Music]